Islam that is establishing a Masjid and
a community center every person who
prays in this Masjid every child that
memorized the Quran you will inshallah
share in that reward donate it now guys
and do not delay
[Music]
Ed brothers and sisters and dear friends
I don't know if you guys have heard the
latest controversy since I'm a
controversial person no it wasn't me
slapping a woman it was Dana White Dana
White was seen in a club
drinking alcohol and we know the evils
of alcohol is a matter of all evils
which leads to domestic abuse especially
when England loses and in different
places but don't know why it got upset
for whatever reason it may be well maybe
because his wife or his girlfriend
slapped him first now he got slapped
first and then he said you know what let
me slap her back now some people might
say how can she slap but that's a
different topic here the topic here at
10 is what is that she slapped him now
many people have lost their mind over
this
not that she slapped him by the way the
fact that he slapped her back now as you
guys know brothers and sisters we
condemn any kind of violence towards
anybody and unjustified you know if
somebody's coming to attack you that's
no different story but the problem is
the following
if amen was to go to a woman and slap
her face
there will be absolute out uproar
rightly so but what we're feeling to
understand is that those who call for
equality and that gender is you know a
social construct whatever it may be that
a woman
slaps a man and the man slapping her
back
so she's been slapped and he's slapped
in the back and there's an upro not that
she slapped him but the fact that he
slapped her back
the point is here now before we carry on
yes before we carry him because I can
say you know what as a Muslim man what a
religion teaches us and whatever it may
be that 100 if a woman was trying to
slap me I mean the most I'm going to do
is just hold her you know try to
restrain her and just you know say you
know look I don't want to hurt you
because you know if I was to touch you
you'd probably die so I'm just going to
try to restrain 100 but it's the double
standard and hypocrisy now we have this
individual which we're going to react to
now who for some odd reason believes in
equal rights but only if it comes to
Woman let's see what he has to say
defending Dana White's actions and
saying that because he was slapped first
it's all good
All is fair
okay so what you saw there from sisters
now I if I'm looking from a perspective
from an outside perspective and I'm
looking like this is the world view that
you follow I would have to call this MMA
fighters and say you know what actually
from their world view point of view
they're just trying to be they don't
want to be Hypocrites they don't have
double standards and they're just like
look you know what at the end of the day
if we believe gender is a social
construct a man hitting a woman or a
woman hitting a man they are both acting
on violence so what some of the MMA
fights are saying is well let's be
consistent here so I can say okay from
their worldview which I don't agree with
at least they're having some kind of
consistency but this man is not happy
about it let's find out why equal rights
excuse me where I come from you get
slapped by a woman 10 times you walk
away
I'm sorry okay and who the hell said you
set the standards off where I come from
um where I come from if you get slapped
by a woman ten times you walk away yeah
who sets these standards and who sets
the number 10 why not five why not 20.
what about if she turns or decides to
pick up a baseball bat or let's say a
knife or even a gun
what on What Paradigm do we put a stop
to and say well here you can't do that
who decides that you
so the question I'm asking very simply
who said that you can set to this
standard of where I come from I don't
give it down where the hell you come
from I'm sorry if that if if that to you
feels like I don't believe in equal
rights then fine because to me equal
rights is 100 agree equal rights now
we're talking let's see what he has to
offer treating women fairly treating
women like we want to be treated women
get paid the same get the same
opportunities that's equal rights hold
on a second we started off good so here
he was talking about equal rights enough
for you know what this man is going to
be just so let me get this right to your
standards an equal right no not equal
right you want an unequal right so
basically you are acknowledging
biologically anatomically physically
spiritually whatever you want to name it
dear that she's in a disadvantaged
position 100 percent how is that
equality that you are seeing I wouldn't
want this woman to treat me the way I
would like to treat you duh hello yes do
you not understand the hypocrisy that
you've just uttered I would like to be
treated the way you uh how you treat me
but you are the same person that's
saying that if she slaps you and where
you're from we don't know where you're
from by the way yeah where you're from
if she slaps you ten times that you just
walk away
I mean is there anything else that needs
to be said except that I am starting to
believe that you're a simp now I'm
starting to believe that you are a simp
because anybody in the right man that's
watching this will say hold on I said
it's making contradictory statements
this man is not making sense to me at
all yeah and he keeps talking about
where he's from which we don't know
where he's from and he is an outright
simp because if you want to be treated
the same way meaning Dana White does not
want to be slapped
he has a right to that so then how is it
that you're saying yes you have a right
not to be slapped but when you do get
stabbed you're not allowed to slap back
are you stupid to me it seems like you
are so desperate to get a woman that you
are saying things that you don't even
acknowledge yourself because only a
person who is desperate would say such
thing is is cognitive dissonance right
literally bro if you think about it only
a desperate man I'll be honestly I had
friends who are very desperate and they
would see anything to get girls and you
remind me of them in a nutshell that's
it is there anything else Adam please
Brothers and Sisters Let's be just here
okay so basically in a nutshell you guys
heard what he had to say now the fact
that Dana White is not defending he's
he's come out well guess what maybe look
at the stock the shares of UFC and see
what's happened to it maybe that's the
reason why Dynamite has come out for
whatever reason it may be just because
he came out and said oh I don't you know
I should have not Etc you know imagine a
woman who's being abused yeah and comes
and says no no you know he loves me he
hates me because he loves me would he be
justified Would We Believe It Or would
we say oh my God she's been manipulated
or she's she's he probably beat her up
before she made the statement why the
double standards this is the point that
we're trying to point near brothers and
sisters and like he said before so what
if a UFC fighter a woman Amanda Nunes
imagine Amanda Nunes comes to you and
you said where I'm funny if you give me
10 stop what I should give you one stop
you die yeah okay are you gonna say oh
okay let me be okay with it no she's
physically stronger than you she can
slap you she can cause you harm she can
kill you so why is there double standard
that's all we want to say brown sisters
do you agree disagree comment section
below inshallah and send this to this
individual whoever he is inshallah till
next time
is establishing a Masjid and a community
center every person who prays in this
Masjid every child that memorized the
Quran you will inshallah share in that
reward donate now guys and do not delay